Frances imbolg WA is boss of a company
challenge gift bags inca bt a town just
outside the Kenyan capital Nairobi his
staff of 15 make carrier bags out of
recycled paper with handles of plated
Bach the aim is to find a replacement
for plastic bags I was seeing the effect
of Paula Deen papers number degradable
bugs is too much especially in our
country some places that we used to go
take hours to grace when you I am we can
no longer do that because the paper the
Nell papers are covered you know the
soil and all vegetations can be done
from there the river and the road here
of who of plastic trash it poisons the
water and hinders the flume cleaning it
away is an uphill struggle the coop
shops are a major culprit food is
delivered wrapped in plastic and then
sold also in plastic and all that
plastic then ends up in the bin project
started challenge our lives as far as
the environment we are in this concern
it's a program we are buying
realize that we have potentially we can
be able to do something out of things
that people doesn't like business is
good Francis and bagua also joins in
especially when developing products for
new customers a number of youngsters
from cavity have found work at his
company
James karaoke is 20 he was trained on
the job and is now one of the firm's
most experienced members of staff I've
worked in this place for seven years
it's a really good job and it secures my
livelihood yes I depend on it to sustain
my life the bags sell for 30 to 40 euros
cents each more than 50 businesses are
regular customers and Frances in Hoover
wants to develop new products that can
fit these other nylons that are very
cheap a bug that can somebody who sells
which can put in the support that they
need Atlanta fire the main customers are
hotels and upmarket shops but if
challenged gift bags can increase sales
that should mean there will be fewer
plastic bags disfiguring and polluting
the environment a small but significant
victory for environmental protection in
Kenya